my friends I have to tell you I am
flattered I'm humbled I'm grateful I I
don't even know what word to use for the
stunning outpouring of Support over the
last 24 hours after I communicated to
you the existential threat to the David
Pacman show as a result of the right
wing mob sent after me by Donald Trump
Jr and by Sean Hannity and Candace Owens
and everybody which included trying to
bully our advertisers into pulling their
support for my show because I had the
audacity to tweet that thoughts and
prayers don't stop shootings even at a
Christian School where they pray all the
time and that something must be done
they pretended not to realize that I'm
obviously not blaming the dead children
and they activated and it has been an
insane 48 hours so first the bad news
this is just it's not good
some advertisers have pulled their
support period they don't want to hear
reason I'm not going to tell you which
ones because I don't want you to now go
and Target them right I mean but but you
will notice that some advertisers are
going to be gone from our videos over
the next immediate period of time
but
check out the response from a couple of
our advertisers one who said publicly
they have to be neutral so please don't
say who we are but they said in response
to us saying listen here's what's going
on
they said quote we advocate for free
speech therefore we are not concerned
with David's comments we would prefer to
continue the partnership and stand up to
those who are looking to destroy freedom
of speech
we also uh have a second Advertiser that
wrote to Noah Noah handles our all of
our ads and says I've been monitoring
the situation and while we're seeing
some emails both in opposition to and in
support of David it's nothing too crazy
no emails from any of our actual
customers though they all claim to be
and this is as I've said
the people trying to get us canceled
with our advertisers they're not my
viewers and they're also not the
customers of any of our advertisers
this Advertiser went on to say
personally I'm so incredibly tired of
the outrage economy discourse that now
thrives on social media and those like
Miss Owens Candace Owens that promote it
the mob mentality has fully taken hold
if these people were even half as mad
about the constant school shootings as
they are about a now deleted tweet
maybe there would be some progress on
the issue just like every faux outrage
event I'm sure this will all blow over
in a few days once there is something
new for people to complain about
appreciate you putting our ads on hold
for a bit we told our advertisers we
won't run anything for the rest of this
week because we don't want all of your
the videos with your ads to be filled
with anti-submitic comments appreciate
putting the ads on hold for a bit we've
been really happy with our sponsorship
of David's show and look forward to
working with him in the future that is
inspiring to see from advertisers who
see this for what it is we also saw some
really great videos published by our
friends and colleagues Kyle kolinsky and
Jesse dollimore Kyle put out a video
called Candace Owens attacks David
Pacman where Kyle brilliantly breaks
down the obviously contrived right-wing
mob over an obvious tweet about how
thoughts and prayers don't stop
shootings Jesse dollimore put out a
video called David pakman is being
attacked by Donald Trump Jr and other
right-wing ghouls where he also espouses
total moral and factual clarity about
the situation but even more important we
love Jesse and Kyle but even more
important is all of you
look at the response from all of you I
asked you please subscribe to the
YouTube channel because imagine the
message we would send
to this targeted right-wing mob by
coming out of this with a bigger YouTube
channel and you did more than 5 000 of
you subscribe to the YouTube channel
just yesterday and it's already on fire
today
thank you I asked you email our
advertisers tell them stick with David
that is actual viewers support you
hundreds of you cc'd me on thousands of
emails to advertisers
nearly 50 people started new patreon
pledges at patreon.com davidpackman show
another 40 of you signed up for the
premium newsletter via sub stack but
listen to this that I I I'm a big strong
guy but I almost have tears in my eyes
as Donald Trump would say
over 700 new website members in the last
24 hours we created this coupon code
exactly to track this the code is cancel
cancel the idea is cancel the counselors
cancel cancel and that code works at
joinpakman.com
as of 9 A.M this morning
478 new members signed up with that code
and over 700 new members in total a
couple hundred of you didn't even use
the code you paid full price and if I
look right now
they're coming in one every two minutes
it is unbelievable
so listen The Advertiser losses are
significant I can't will that away it's
just the reality
but some of our advertisers see this for
what it is
the new memberships are helping to
offset those losses and maybe most
importantly those YouTube subscriber
growth numbers are really a signal that
my actual audience not the people who
now are coming oh I used to love your
show now our actual audience gets the
whole point of this
thoughts and prayers don't stop mass
shootings whether it's at a Christian
school or a secular school that's really
what this is about so thank you
keep subscribing keep the memberships
going I can't tell you how much I
appreciate it and come Monday we'll see
where everything stands but what a 48
Hours let's now get back to the really
important stuff that's going on